somebody who I've known for quite some
time good to see you from the New York
Football Giants with Gatorade Eli
Manning how are you served only fitting
that you're clutching a bottle of
Gatorade right now only fitting because
I do believe it was the first time that
we met I'm going to bring this up it was
in the city of Houston that's right it
was the first ever Super Bowl the NFL
Network had ever covered it was Tom
Brady beating the Carolina Panthers
eventually but you and the entire
Manning family strolled into the
Gatorade suite before ahead and uh in
the sack one night yeah correct that was
it and who did you hear singing karaoke
in the Gatorade suite that night it was
a beautiful voice
would you say that was in terms of it
was like an angel bringing us in in
there who walk in and we see see Rich
Eisen karaoke dominating to basically by
the way nobody else in the room practice
there was my me and my buddy
there was nobody what what song good
question ultra Sinatra I forget which
one it okay seriously it was me and my
buddy we join right in did you you did
sing right you guys all did get on their
mind if we got up there you know I can't
turn that down
no I know it was me honestly man
obviously like priests telephone play
pretty pretty light you know I had a
camera you don't worry about anybody
don't think twice it was just a moment
yeah that's a moment you do have to
memorize it
who's me my buddy Doug and then it was I
think your entire face your mom and your
dad you know and you and Peyton and
cover cover yeah exactly
and what do you have a go-to karaoke
song you I know it's changed over the
years obviously yeah you're gonna go
with the time so you know Footloose has
always been one you know just cuz you
can kind of dance with it but now you
know it's it's tough it's tough to do
karaoke now there's no worried you know
people are filming all the signs and a
judge and
just enough I don't need to be too
serious Eli Manning here on the Rich
Eisen show so now your dad played here
for a couple of seasons right do you
have any reckless you were three right
obviously yeah I was three years old so
no III don't remember it but you didn't
live here though right here we came for
a fall so he came yeah we just came here
one one season that we lived up here so
we can't eat came you know came up
September and we made it to my mom made
it to about Thanksgiving and she said
all right I'm going down south with the
with the Ducks
and and so but Peyton so Peyton the
other day I mean he was I would see
eight could burst in you know they went
to school here and everything they went
they went to the old house my pain went
to the old house rang the doorbell and
you know what went inside for a little
bit went to the high school into the
through the third grade school
remembered his teacher's name and and
asked if she was still there she wasn't
but uh you know he wouldn't kind of got
the you know the old tour so again
Payton goes to the front door yeah of
some Minneapolis residents house yes and
number eighteen right yeah rings rings a
doorbell he says someone kind of you
know it's like a you know could talk in
and he said a I I lived in this house
back in 1984 and I was wondering and if
I could come in and look around and the
person says Payton I'm at work right now
but I'll be there in one minute he goes
how did you know it was me that I'm
looking at yeah I got a camera up or
something like this guy bought the house
in 1985 right after you know right after
you know we my dad rented it and he
bought it that next year and been there
since and obviously knew that my dad had
stayed there prior so he was happy to
give give Payton my mom a little tour of
the of the house I didn't go I was doing
something and I didn't remember it
anyway but it's amazing so somebody had
to tell their boss here in Minneapolis I
gotta go run home right to let Payton
and Olivia Manning into the house that
you still
and I'm sure the boss is like yeah okay
so where where are things for you do you
think with the Giants have you spoken
with Pat Sherman yeah with Coach Shermer
and he's excited you know I'm excited to
work together and you know hey I
understand in this league it's it's kind
of a what have you done for me lately
and understand hey I gotta go and
improve I can still play and compete I'm
not giving it I'm gonna be giving that
opportunity but I it's you're always
competing you're always competing for
your job and so but I think you know
that's that's where I am and excited
about that opportunity to go and fix
things and play good football so what
was the toughest thing about last year
for you Eli losing games you know that's
that's what's that's that's always the
toughest part obviously not not starting
not not having that opportunity was was
it tough but you know the outreach in
them and the teammates the fans the
support I got from coaches from from you
know players around the league was
unbelievable and I appreciate that
helped me get through that it reminded
me I had I need to be a good teammate
during this situation it's not you know
this is about being a good person
handling it the right way and so I tried
to you know do be ready help out the
team and do whatever I could do to not
make it a you know awkward and you know
try to go out and get a win well John
Mara said that if he was physically
there during that week where you were
informed that a streak was going to end
that perhaps none of that would have
happened he intimated that would you
agree right as well I tried I mean I
talked to I talked to John Mayer you
know I kind of cinema tax ask if he was
in town or at the office he said he
wasn't and so it's just time I probably
should have called him and had a
conversation before you know some of
this stuff was going down and the
conversations that you know having coach
McAdoo so you know yeah yeah I
understand we're at that point we'd won
two games rather playoffs and when
you're in that situation you know
nothing good you know can happen and so
I don't you know i don't i don't you
know i don't blame coach McAdoo or Jerry
Ries for help
went down I I take I take responsibility
for for you know the play and not win
enough games and I feel bad about how
you know when you lose a head coach head
coach he's fired you know it's a quarter
but you should take that personal and
I'd do it means I didn't do my job and
so I didn't want anything to go down and
it was tough but that's this part of
part of football sometimes a couple more
questions on this and then we'll hit
Gatorade in Super Bowl fifty two with
Eli Manning have you had a conversation
with Pat Shermer management gentleman at
all about what they intend to do with
the second overall pick I don't want you
to give her an 80 trade secrets but did
you flat-out point-blank ask them or if
they told you with no plan to do it no
no I don't know if they know right now
you know they're still hey you know
obviously that rumors been there one
week he's trying to figure out you know
his coaching staff and what's gonna
happen in the draft so you know I think
there's a chin you know I think there's
a you know you probably draft a
quarterback somewhere and and if that
our I don't know if probably but that's
a chance and that happens hey I'm okay
with that I can I can handle that I
understand I am 37 years old I don't I
don't know how many more years and so
you got a plan for whether it's this
year for the future and and you know I
hope I'm part of that future part of the
plan and I think I still got a lot of
you know years left to play football at
a high level because I work with Kurt
Warner I mean that was very similar to
the situation of you being drafted in
him being there obviously he didn't have
as many years with the Giants
organization is clearly you right right
so I mean it's an interesting so the
last one do you want to finish your
career with the Giants
yeah I deal yes yeah you definitely you
know I think when you come in and you
you start with an organization it's
always you know the mind said you'd like
to finish with them it doesn't happen as
much nowadays with free agency and guys
bouncing around but yeah ideally you
know it's only organization I know you
know the people in there from from the
mayor's the tissues all the way down to
you know the people in the cafeteria to
the video guys to the training room to
the way you know you they're like family
and so you know don't don't have any
desire to go play anywhere else okay so
you are obviously you know
known as a patriot killer a Brady a
Brady Slayer however you want to put it
and you know the Eagles better than
anybody do you see anything on the
Eagles that would be similar to the
years that you took the Patriots down in
the Superbowl well I think from a
defensive standpoint the Eagles their
defensive line it's pretty similar I
think you know to those usually player
when you had talked and you had OSI and
and you know the other years of jpp and
you know be able to get a pass rush you
know can you can you disrupt brain I
want you to mention Strahan so he
doesn't get pissed at you the next time
I mention straight I don't know I just
heard talking OC I always know my first
year spoke with Michael this morning
okay we're guys you know so you know so
I think they can if they you know that
defense line shows up and plays the way
they can and disrupts him a little bit
and he goes off it's false is playing
good football you know he's a he's got
play smarter you got beat turnover free
and those things so they they have the
ingredients analysis can they play their
best foot can Eagles play their best
football their best defense in the
fourth quarter because that's usually
when you know Tom you know it gets close
and it's good scream you know crunch
time he's at his best and that's a great
ones are and so can they can they amp up
that that defensive pressure makes a
place yeah and how much do you think
experience matters in this game you know
like an experience as it played in Super
Bowls before I don't think I'm a suit
you know the first time we played you
know Brady them a Super Bowl lot of our
guys have never been there they'd won
won championships a force I don't think
it I think it's it's hey are you playing
good football you got good players you
got a good scheme and and I think Foles
folds this kind of relaxed guy doesn't
seem like much to you know he's not to
be nervous going into it so I think
they'll be I think they'll be fine okay
so what style of Gatorade is your
Gatorade flow it's the realest line it's
a little smoother finish so it's just
like any Gator it's just a little like
every athlete needs different things to
fuel themselves everybody also has
different tastes so this is just a
different just a different taste a
little smoother it is a pineapple mango
I know it's one of your favorite amazing
oh man so I brought this I brought this
for you oh thank you very much so I want
you to have that okay I got to stay
hydrated so what you know it's a three
hour show this is very beginning of the
three hour show I don't want to cramp up
you know I'm saying it's and I did a
long week here maybe I should however
hold on to this for when I run my 40 yes
I've seen that because sometimes you
know I on occasion because I'm saying
just after and after well there's a
couple I I'm not just a one take runner
usually I don't just break it and then
just stop I usually eyes a couple of
runs at it so would you suggest I take
it before or in-between my runs or
during after yes and the night before
and you know keep going fantastic hey
Eli you are the man I greatly appreciate
it and speak I will say this I know I
don't care if I'm gonna Barris you
speaking on behalf of New Yorkers in New
Jersey i'ts and cuz I grew up there in
Staten Island and I still have roots
there what you stand for and how you've
gone about your business for the New
York Football Giants the outcry that had
happened this year and I think speaks to
how people feel about you in the way
you've conducted yourself in that in
that environment so thank you know you
that you Batman just so congratulations
on that for the left Congrats on making
it through all those years and winning
twice and but the way you conduct
yourself you are you are the man oh
thanks thanks so much you bet the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience